ces vues du canada où il y à 150 ans une
vaste région désertique s'étendait entre
les rocheuses canadiennes et le
pacifique
cette région était traversée par un
fleuve et ce fleuve n'avaient pas de nom
et pas encore d'histoire
un homme en 1808 simon frazer pour ne
rien vous cacher décide de partir à sa
découverte
une rencontre loeffler il sait qu'il
prend sa source dans un pâturage à élan
une fois que simon fraser a rencontré le
fleuve il a un coup de foudre pour lui
et lui donne son nom au pied du mont
europe sonne le fleurs commencent à
s'étendre
le voilà à sa naissance
ici voyez vous au pied du mont robson en
sept ans et sur 800 m
il décrit une immense lettre s jusqu'à
l'océan
il a des affluents comme tout fan qui se
respecte et ses affluents sont les vous
dire quesnel et thomson
il descend les montagnes de gorge
d'angor ne recule devant rien
elle se fait impétueux dangereux même
regardez ce tourbillon au centre de
l'image
et il le secteur à son embouchure en un
vaste dette
il a son histoire il a aussi son destin
de du jour de sa découverte
silence de 50 ans et soudain un bruit
extraordinaire se répondent le frazer
est remplie d'or en un an 2000
prospecteurs à fut une colonie se
forment bien entendu et les envahisseurs
fouille tout le temps
le ni ni du fleuve toute une race
d'aventuriers qui risquent
quotidiennement leur fille s'installe
malgré les obstacles et l'hostilité des
jungles l'or attire
e
mais il faut faire vivre cette nouvelle
ville sur pilotis qui viennent se
construire il faut la faire vivre et
pour cela ils font une route
le gouverneur du grès l'obtient et les
commerçants à leur tour envahi ce pays
puisqu'il y à de l'or il y a de l'argent
à gagner et c'est l'époque où le
champagne la musique et les danseuses
peu détournée et bien des cas
mais toutes ces maisons vont un jour se
guider car
le sol se cuit
et font du gore l'euphorie disparaît la
ville de vintimille fantôme tout le
monde s'en est allé il n'y a plus rien à
faire ici
le fleuve continuent à couler
la ville est morte
comme ceux ci qui sont restés à jamais
ici
d'or bella d'or
un an
mais la nature réserve toujours à
l'homme ses ressources et les épaisses
forêts sont une nouvelle vie chère c'est
certainement une source de revenus moins
brillant peut-être mais plus stable et
nos chercheurs d'or des chevaux de
forrest est à nouveau le frazer
intervient il se le voient
le rôle qu'on lui donne est vraiment à
sa mesure vous voyez c'est énorme bio et
bien c'est le frazer qui va les
transporter
et la sagesse trouve souvent sa
récompense car l'industrie du bois est
aujourd'hui la première de la province
et alors dans le cercil delta du fleuve
se construire des fermes
on y élever des vaches laitières et ce
fut la prospérité
mais les indiens étaient toujours là et
il s'était réconcilié avec l'homme blanc
et il a pris un certain à pêcher le
saumon qui remonte le fleuve à l'époque
du fret
nouvelles richesses naturelles a
exploité par l'homme et le frazer
devient bientôt le premier centre de
production de saumon au monde
voilà sept buts splendides
les indiens n'avait certainement pas ces
procédés pour opérer leur travail devait
être beaucoup plus lent mais beaucoup
plus pénible est certainement moins
rentable aussi
et d'autres pionniers pendant ce temps
élève des chevaux une fois lens déroule
de grande fête pour évoquer les
souvenirs du temps jadis
parmi ces fêtes le rodéo bien entendu le
rodez
là
mais dans les montagnes il faut aussi
penser à l' isolement et il faut vaincre
cet isolement des montagnes alors les
habitants réclamaient un chemin de fer
ni eu d'énormes difficultés pour
accrocher la voie ferrée aux étroites
saillie la montagne se défend des elle
tenait à son isolement
mais l'homme lui n'en voulait pas et il
faut le poupon aujourd'hui ce ruban
d'acier que vous voyez sous vos yeux
foule ensemble l'est et l'ouest du
canada
puis au diable l'avarice et puisque les
choses avaient aussi d un marché un
deuxième chemin de fer fut construit sur
le versant opposé la promenade doit être
belle j'avoue que j'aimerais aussi la
faire
mais sur terre il n'y a pas que les
chemins de fer qui roule on pensa à une
grande route une route nationale
transcanadienne qui en pointe est tout
simplement l'ancienne piste du caribou
il lui fallut tantôt percer la montagne
tantôt la contourner il ne faut jamais
affronter de face un adversaire trop
fort aujourd'hui là aussi l'homme un
triomphe
tout ceci pour arriver à vancouver
cette ville est construite qui est la
troisième du canada en importance cette
ville est construite à l'endroit même
une phrase un se jette dans l'océan
le frazer achemine à vancouver les
produits de l'intérieur loum aux
provinces de l'est
l'accès du pacifique et les bateaux de
50 nations viennent s'y approvisionner
en produits canadiens à vous et vous
allez tout de même la peine de le
découvrir
je
et je suis longtemps que le frazer
laisse dans la mer la trace de ses eaux
brunes
parmi les eaux bleues du pacifique
irène chagnaud vous a proposé voyage
sans passeport cette émission a été
réalisée avec le concours de l'office
national du film canadien et de solange
peters ont animé des scripts lucette en
venir illustration sonore dominique pas
l'animent